es momento de hablar de economía en
france24 y para ello me acompaña mi
compañera daniela blandón en el estudio
daniela buenas noches bienvenida y
empezamos en australia que es el primer
país del mundo en hacer que google y
facebook paguen por sus contenidos
noticiosos valentina buenas noches pues
tras su aprobación en el senado esta
polémica ley está lista para entrar en
vigencia pero los gigantes tecnológicos
lograron que se hicieran cambios de
última hora para que no los volveré tan
duro uno de ellos es que tendrán un año
para llegar a acuerdos con las empresas
de noticias si no lo logran un árbitro
será quien establezca una remuneración
justa para las empresas de medios por
sus contenidos lo cierto es que ambas
empresas ya han venido avanzando en este
punto google lo hizo con news corp y
conserve nuestra envidia y facebook está
en conversaciones con otros más aunque
australia es pionero en este tipo de
medidas reino unido y canadá están
contemplando legislaciones similares la
experta en a ojeda nos explicó más
temprano qué consecuencias tendrá esto
para las empresas
consecuencia económica que va a traer
para google y para facebook que es que
van a tener que sentarse a negociar con
los medios de comunicación seguramente
los grandes y los medianos dudo que
google facebook quiera sentarse con los
pequeños
medios de comunicación a negociar y pues
además de esto va a traer una
repercusión bastante importante porque
van a tener que se embolsillan un buen
porcentaje de sus ganancias para pagar a
los medios de comunicación lo cual yo
creo que es bastante interesante porque
va a democratizar un poco el juego
que evidentemente está haciendo
dominados de hace años por las grandes
20 que daniela y continuamos en
nicaragua porque ya se fijó el aumento
del salario mínimo en el ajuste de
salariales regirá por los próximos 12
meses hasta el 28 de febrero de 2022 y
se logró por consenso entre el gobierno
los empleadores y los sindicatos no
participaron los representantes de las
grandes empresas valentina porque están
distanciadas del ejecutivo desde hace
casi tres años el alza será del 2,9 por
ciento o un poco más de cinco dólares es
decir pasa de 181 a 186 dólares desde el
primero de marzo
según cifras oficiales esto hay que
decirlo también el actual salario mínimo
es en este país un poco menos de la
mitad de lo que cuesta la canasta básica
y ahora vamos a méxico y argentina que
quieren retomar negociaciones para un
acuerdo comercial si terminó la visita
de tres días del presidente argentino a
méxico con la promesa de retomar las
negociaciones para un acuerdo comercial
alberto fernández y andrés manuel lópez
obrador emitieron una declaración de 15
puntos y en lo que tiene que ver con
economía ya hay un compromiso concreto
valentina el país azteca dijo que abrirá
su mercado a las carnes argentinas en
los mismos términos en que actualmente
aplica a las carnes uruguayas daniela y
los adultos mayores en eeuu son los que
más están aumentando sus compras por
internet
esto es fascinante valentina mire la
pandemia ha traído un aumento
vertiginoso en las compras eso no es un
secreto pero en eeuu está ocurriendo
algo muy llamativo las personas de la
tercera edad están yendo más a menudo de
compras por un medio al que se habían
resistido antes internet la firma de
investigación
analizo estos hábitos de consumo y
encontró que los ciudadanos de más de 65
años compraron en línea un promedio de
187 dólares por mes en 2020 todavía
están lejos del promedio nacional de 238
dólares mensuales y más todavía que el
del rango de 35 a 44 años que gastaron
en promedio 306 dólares al mes sin
embargo esos 187 dólares son un 60 por
ciento más que un año atrás y los
convierte en el grupo de edad con el
crecimiento más rápido valentina daniela
vamos con los indicadores económicos
wall street en cerró en rojo hay un
fenómeno bursátil que se viene dando
hace unos días y es que los bonos del
tesoro de eeuu están muy atractivos y
por eso se ha perdido cierto interés en
las acciones de esta la razón las bolsas
europeas se hicieron lo propio aunque la
caída fue menor y en américa latina la
bolsa de sao paulo volvió a terreno
negativo en medio de la volatilidad de
petrobras por último daniel a la cifra
del día tiene que ver con la buena hora
de los commodities valentina los precios
del petróleo están en maxi
de un año por cuenta de la oleada de
frío en eeuu 63 53 dólares por barril de
w y de referencia en el golfo de méjico
y el cobre se cotiza a 43 dólares en la
libra y se aproxima a su mayor valor de
la historia que fue de 4,6 dólares una
muy buena noticia para chile porque es
su principal producto de exportación
daniela gracias por toda esta
información y ustedes gracias por
continuar con nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]